so nate silver you guys may remember
nate from the election he is the Guru of
predicting elections he runs the
fivethirtyeight blog he just went over
to ESPN so he's already dominated the
political sphere he's moving over to the
sports world in 2008 he correctly
predicted the winner of 49 of the 50
states in the presidential election the
only state he missed was Indiana which
was 1.4 Obama everybody loves this guy
and he did an interview with Deadspin
talking about the political climate and
television and pundits and all that
let's take a look obviously there is
some sports pundits who are total hacks
but I'd argue that most political
pundits are completely useless the
outliers are the few who are actually
worth reading plus the political pundits
take themselves very seriously read the
new mark leibovich book whereas I think
someone like jay mariotti realized that
he's just trolling people okay so jay
mariotti is a sports writer obviously
mark Leibovich just wrote this book
about how Washington is such an inside
nepotistic psychotic bastion of lunacy
okay so now I like to believe that I'm
someone that's talking politics
sometimes out there in the public sphere
and you guys are joining me for the ride
but I do think he has a great point on
this you know again CNN's bringing back
crossfire idiot from the left arguing
with the hack from the right and they
usually work for one administration
there like that and you know what they
think MSNBC is now hired almost everyone
that has ever worked for Obama Fox hires
karl rove and sarah palin on the other
side is he right though like are there
but are there a couple people that are
genuinely i'm trying to do that here
yeah i don't think people but because
you have your own venue you know and and
like a person like Andrew Sullivan has
his own venue and he's not bought and
paid for by whatever think tank or
heritage foundation or whatever to
constantly be spouting the talking
points on this channel in that channel
or whatever just because we have these
24-hour news channels does not mean that
we have 24 hours worth of things to talk
about yeah so they fill them with people
who are just paid employees of whatever
side who go out and give a very shallow
argument and then
yeah but in a very shallow way and it's
a and yet taken very seriously and their
predictions are taken very seriously I
love a person like nate silver who
simply does the statistical analysis
right he does hardcore numbers and it's
proven to work if he's a stud okay this
thing is numbers then he could just say
by looking at the numbers and the sheer
volume of people now talking about
politics is by the way ten years ago our
news didn't talk about politics so much
or MSNBC CNN it's all political pundits
politics politics politics he could just
look at and say by sheer numbers you're
gonna have you know ninety percent of
people are gonna be or whatever his
number is are gonna be you know spouting
off you know just basically hot air or
whatever their stuff is for their side
without any heavy analysis but there's
got to be something a little more
personal because he's also going after
the people at Politico he's going after
a lot of different kind of news ish
organizations that are online and saying
that they're just also hacks right he's
a major thing with political yeah I
don't know it's like this he hates that
he's like you know we're talking about
they really have nothing to say then
he'll contribute to anything I think
he's actually says him about Huffington
Post at some point so he's gone after
different organizations anyway saying
that they're really not contributing
anything of value to you know the
political world but you know I think we
are in that 24-hour news cycle now where
everyone's kind of giving opinions and
if you look at it rather than these are
not you know these aren't facts and
people giving teaching you had a think
and just opinions and you can navigate
it well but he definitely does have a
point I don't know what is beef is
specifically with jay mariotti either
he's like yeah that's like Politico or
Jay mariotti i would say sports writers
know that what they're doing is
essentially frivolous it creates a lot
of money but it's there it's basically
they're talking about a game right there
kind of smiling as their arguing right
rather uh but political pundits think
that what they do is very very serious
yeah and it's just a silly yeah I mean
ultimately it's just sitting
you